[Music]
before hurricane ida weakened to a
tropical storm it slashed through highly
populated areas in louisiana wind gusts
in baton rouge topped 60 miles an hour
overnight
janet chamlion is there good morning
janet michelle good morning to you we
are under a tropical storm warning right
now we've got wind and intermittent rain
and about half of this city is without
power because the storm moved through
through here much later than it did new
orleans under the cover of darkness
though we really won't know the full
extent of the damage here until crews
are out to get into neighborhoods in the
next hour or two janet you covered
hurricane katrina 16 years ago to the
day
how does this compare
so hurricane katrina came through new
orleans it came on shore as a very
strong
tropical i mean her category 3 hurricane
but it wasn't the landfall that was so
devastating it was the aftermath it was
the floodgates and the levees that were
breached in new orleans and elsewhere
inundating 80 percent of the city of new
orleans
with water and when you talk about the
death toll we still don't have an exact
number on that but the estimates are
1800 people died during hurricane
katrina we do know that tens of
thousands of people lost their homes
some 400 000
left the city never to return and in the
aftermath everything changed i mean the
levees were rebuilt the pumps the sea
walls the flood gates all to withstand
as much as 30 feet of water what hasn't
changed is the power grid and we're
seeing this morning
basically all of new orleans without
power and again here in baton rouge
about half of the city without power
125 billion dollars in damage
1800 lives colossal failure of the
levees system but a lot of people
pointed fingers at the leadership both
at the local state and federal level
do you feel as though or do you see a
better preparation this time around
well i think it all comes down to having
a partnership between the federal
government led by the army corps of
engineers to completely redo that system
i mean it was antiquated and it was
never going to be able to cover a storm
of that size do people take hurricanes
more seriously now in new orleans and
surrounding areas absolutely i was
driving east on interstate 10
while everybody was going the opposite
direction towards texas
and it was it looked like a parking lot
for about an hour and a half because of
people leaving and you know we saw
people leaving
in advance of hurricane katrina
but but nothing like i saw you know two
days ago now yes i know thank you janet
you know so many of us remember yes very
vividly the days during uh the storm and
i say it wasn't just the storm that hit
but the levee failures the next day
and then the weeks that followed the the
evacuation of so many people to houston
and elsewhere who still haven't some of
those people still have never returned
to new orleans which i also find
interesting i saw a story yesterday in
the ninth ward that it's now less than
40 percent of the people that used to
live there they still haven't recovered
but they seem to have learned some
lessons that prevented
and the federal government devastation
this time yeah i mean it's hard to
remember but like the fema director when
katrina hit michael brown had no
experience in disasters congress
actually passed a law after they said
you gotta have disaster experience if
you're gonna run fema now they're
putting things in place ahead of time
also interesting
during katrina they said to the public
don't go out and try to rescue people
yeah now we've got team rubicon we've
got the cajun navy we've got all these
good samaritans who are making a real
difference and supporting those first
responders so it's a whole different
ballgame different ball game but still a
lot of work to do down there in
louisiana
some of you are leaving us right now for
the rest of you we're going to take a
little break we'll be back with more
from louisiana as our coverage of
hurricane ida continues you're watching
cbs this morning